what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have the ability to do something
really special and I want to play a
small part in your success through these
videos that I'm making and so to help
you on your journey today I'm continuing
the how billionaires think success
advice from the top series volume three
and as always guys as you're watching if
you hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down comments
below put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired and when you
write it down it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well enjoy
the thing about being an entrepreneur is
this it's just all to you you know a lot
of people like to make excuses I don't
have connections I don't have money I
don't have this but you know if you find
something that you like to do or love to
do be great at it and see if you could
turn it into a business and worst case
you're gonna have fun doing what it is
you love to do in best case you can turn
it into a business I I'm just dumping on
excuses I just think if you really
everybody has an opportunity to go for
it they just kind of do it
turn your wounds into wisdom you will be
wounded many times in your life you'll
make mistakes some people will call them
failures but I have learned that failure
is really God's Way of saying excuse me
you're moving in the wrong direction
it's just an experience
experience just an experience I remember
being taken off the air in Baltimore
being told that I was no longer being
fit for television and that I could not
anger the news because I used to go out
on the stories and my own truth was even
though I'm not a weeper
I would cry for the people in the
stories and which really wasn't very
effective as a news reporter to be
covering a fire and crying because the
people lost us and it wasn't until they
I was demoted as a on-air anchorwoman
and thrown into the talk-show arena to
get rid of me that I allowed my own
truth to come through and the first day
I was on the air doing my first talk
show back in 1978 it felt like breathing
which is what your true passion should
feel like it should be so natural to you
and so I took what had been a mistake
what had been perceived as a failure
with my career as an anchorwoman in the
news business and turned it into a
talk-show career that's done OK for me
you are unusually fearless and willing
to go in the face of other people
telling you something that's crazy
and I know a lot of pretty crazy people
you still stand out where does that come
from or how do you think about making a
decision when everyone tells you this is
a crazy idea where do you get the
internal strength to do that well first
well I'd say I actually think I feel
feel fear quite strongly so it's not as
though I just have the absence of fear
I've I feel it quite strongly but there
were times when something is important
enough you believe it enough that you do
you do it in spite of the fear so
speaking of important things like people
shouldn't think III I should if you
should think well I feel fear about this
and therefore I shouldn't do it it's
normal to be to feel fair like you'd
have to definitely something mentally
wrong you shouldn't feel fair so you
just feel it and let the importance of
it drive you to do it anyway yeah you
know actually something that can be
helpful as fatalism some degree if you
just think it's just accept the
probabilities then that diminishes fear
so I'm starting SpaceX I thought the
odds of success were less than 10% and I
just accepted that actually probably I
would just lose lose everything but that
maybe would make some progress if we
could just move the ball forward even if
we died maybe some other company could
pick up the baton and move and keep
moving it forward so that we still do
some good yeah same with Tesla I thought
your odds of a car company succeeding
were extremely loved
so many things go wrong when you're
starting a company and often I think
people ask you know what mistakes should
you avoid making and you know my answer
that question is don't even bother
trying to avoid mistakes because you're
gonna make tons of mistakes right and
the the important thing is actually
learning quickly from whatever mistakes
you make and not giving up right and I
mean there are things every single year
of Facebook's existence that could have
killed us or made it so that it just
seemed like moving forward and making a
lot of progress just seemed intractable
but you just kind of bounce back and you
learn and nothing is impossible you just
have to kind of keep running through the
walls
is the ideas matter now people say of
course ideas matter what kind of stupid
life lesson is it that ideas matter the
truth of the matter is this is both
under and over appreciated most people
think every idea is a good idea as long
as they had it the truth of the matter
is not every idea is a good idea not
every idea matters and not every idea
should be pursued and if you're in a
field like I am or was of innovation not
every idea is a good idea even if it
strikes you that way I'm first blush in
fact most people are lucky to have one
idea that really matters in their whole
life that's not a criticism but
earth-shattering life-changing ideas are
very few and far between research
insights investment insights innovations
a good idea needs to be cherished and
nurtured
most important thing is you have to
there's two sides is really sort of the
intellectual or mental side you have to
pick a business that has a niche you
have to have a reason to succeed you
have to be something like we were doing
say Japan can beat Germany in
manufacturing of this type of a product
that was the niche really and then on
that you just have to have a total and
complete passion because there's gonna
be so many dark moments you know I think
the dark moments are true for any
entrepreneur or any startup company I'm
sure that you talked to Steve Jobs and
Apple you'd see many many dark dark
moments ours happened to last a little
longer than most of them but you really
emotionally have to be prepared for
those dark moments I think every
entrepreneur I've ever spoken to which
would echo that yeah everything's on the
line that's the life of an entrepreneur
and so you're gonna be into it you'd
better be prepared for that
going against the tide is great if it
works now it doesn't always work and you
really have to be smart to go against
the tide because you're going against a
lot of smart people but when you get it
right you'll end up better
weathers Microsoft or Google I mean so
many people that have really hit big
have gone against the tide but you have
to have great confidence in yourself you
have to be the right person there are
very few people that can pull it off but
when you pull it off it's great
same thing in real estate you go against
the tide people are selling you're
buying the tide changes
the fundamental connection to doing
business is basically relationships you
know people really if you really think
about it people want to do business with
people they like I mean every now and
then you'll do a deal with the devil but
you don't really like the devil but you
have do it sometimes but you really much
rather do business with somebody you
like somebody who shares your values
somebody who you know is committed to
the same objectives you are somebody's
willing to work as hard as you are and
when you find those people those are the
people you want to bring under your tent
to be part of your business objective
and you've got to do that by you know
sort of presenting yourself in a way
that people clearly understand that you
are committed to creating value business
people want to create value it doesn't
mean they don't want to have fun doesn't
mean that they don't want to be involved
in other kinds of things but if you can
say go to someone and convince them that
I can help you create value and by your
ability to articulate that and to
communicate it and to give people the
impression that you will work as hard as
they will to create that value you're
gonna find people wanting to come to you
and so for me it's sort of been like
that throughout my whole career is being
able to to say to people and what talk
to people in a way that convinces them
that I am going to do everything I can
to help make what they want to achieve a
success and by extension I'm going to be
a success when I started a BT the guy
who invested a BET's a guy named John
Maloney it was at that time the operator
the third largest cable company in
Denver Colorado and he kept investing
money and to be et without taking
additional equity and as Beatty became a
big success you know I ended up with
about 75% of the company he ended up
about 25% of the company and one day I
asked him and I say to John John you you
put over a half a million dollars in BTD
on the startup you put it in his debt
you didn't
in his equity which would give him
greater ownership I said why'd you do it
that way and he said Bob I always knew
you would work harder for yourself than
you would for me and it was that kind of
commitment so if you can convey to
people that you're willing to work hard
for them and for yourself you've got a
business party you're connecting the
dots
you know there is there's a very thin
dividing line between success and
failure when you start a business from
scratch and you know if you don't have
enough money to pay the bills
you go the wrong side of that dividing
line and if you can somehow get enough
money to pay the bills
you stay the right side of that dividing
line and and you know we I've always you
know I've always been running running
running faster than perhaps I should me
and I've have great difficulty saying no
to things so keep on taking on new
things and and you know we've we've just
managed to stay the right side of the
dividing line over the last 50 years in
business but but equally in those early
days when you when you're starting a
business without any financial backing
it's it's it's easy to slip the wrong
side and and in fact you know most
entrepreneurs do do slip the wrong side
and the poor the important thing is then
just to you know pick yourself up and
you know start again and if it doesn't
work at that time keep keep going until
you do succeed and not to give up I want
to talk about dreams for a second and in
my case literally a dream when I was in
college I was sure that I've been
admitted by a clerical error
Broly a computer error and because of
that I had an irrational fear I'd be
sent home on the bus and Sergey sure
knows this is true but it turns out
because of that anxiety I woke up
literally with a dream it was kind of a
strange dream it went like I think I
could download the entire web on to some
old computers that were lying around and
that would probably seem pretty crazy to
most people but I stayed up a couple
hours in the middle of the night doing
some math and it seemed actually pretty
plausible well assuming he actually
didn't keep any of the Y pages he only
kept the links and then sort of figured
outs
given all that data I thought I would
take a couple of weeks and I told my
advisor that and he just sort of laughed
to me and of course took a year or two
but at the end of that we had a way to
rank web pages and no thoughts to search
at all and eventually search entered the
picture and you know the rest
and that became Google so next
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you think what did you take in this
video what was the most memorable a most
applicable lesson that you're going to
immediately implement into your life or
your business somehow let me know down
in the comments below I'm looking
forward to hearing what you guys have to
say thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is
much love see you soon